when the covert 19 pandemic first hit
there was a massive global shortage of
medical grade masks
to meet the urgent needs during this
emergency razer quickly responded by
manufacturing high quality
certified medical grade masks for the
frontline workers
today we have donated more than one
million masks globally
but now that we're well and truly
settled into this new normal
we see the need for a face mask that is
safe
social and sustainable introducing
project hazel the world's smartest mask
for safety the masters classified a
surgical n95 respirator
which provides a high fluid resistance
that protects against droplets
and splashes its active ventilation
brings in cool air and releases heat
produced from exhaling
which also prevents a buildup of co2 in
the mask
aside from safety we also looked how we
could improve
social interaction with the mask as most
designs cover the face
and muffle your speech our smart mask
has a clear
transparent design which makes
communicating easier
as others can now see you speak and pick
up your facial cues
thanks to a built-in mic and amplifier
combo our patient pending voice amp
technology
ensures your speech isn't muffled even
when you're masked up
the mask is waterproof and scratch
resistant making it ideal for frequent
use
and because it's made of recyclable
plastic this sustainable design
greatly minimizes wastage as compared to
disposable masks
a smart mask should also be super
comfortable to wear the silicon guard
sits snugly around your face to prevent
air leaking in
and keeps the mask itself from touching
or resting on your mouth so you can talk
naturally
by designing this mask to be safe social
sustainable comfortable and personalized
project hazel is our answer to what the
world's smartest mars can be
bravo i've been practicing my vanna
white skills for this
very moment are you ready i say we do it
ready three two
one go voila this is the official reveal
of the concept
for the world's smartest mask and i
am so excited to dive into the specifics
of this but before we do
i think we need to go over some of the
reasoning that led
to this very moment because in the video
itself you already heard them talking
directly about the impacts that they've
made through mass production yeah you
might have seen it at razercon actually
as soon as the the pandemic started to
hit uh in
all across the world the production
factories razors started producing
mass for frontline workers and actually
the razer community was a big part of
that and actually
making sure that over 1 million masks
were delivered to frontline users so you
and i got a chance to talk to some of
the razer product team about this mask
and really asking what's the next step
that razer can do and here's your first
concept
unveil at ces 2021 it's going to be the
world's smartest mask
and there's exploration here of some
really innovative technology let's talk
about the pillars
of project hazel as you can see on your
screen being
safe social sustainable comfortable and
personalized are at the forefront of the
design of this concept
and first things first talking about the
safety because that is the priority when
it comes to wearing a mask right keeping
yourself safe and you need to make sure
that you have those specific
considerations rather like for instance
it is a surgical
n95 respirator not something that's just
slapped on there it's something that you
can rely upon
yeah absolutely i think other cool two
things that one of them you saw from the
video is going to be the active
ventilation
so that's going to be cool air in and
hot air out which is going to be
fantastic i mean right now
in north america or in the winter and
even in vegas the nights have been
freezing so it's not too bad but i tell
you what
in the heat of the summer especially for
all the all the local folks here in
vegas i know that when it's 112 outside
something like active ventilation in a
mass would be really welcome but also
active sterilization in the mask
as well it's pretty fantastic so that
covers kind of safety
like you said that's going to be
paramount for this type of mass but i
think one of the things that you and i
are most excited about and we talked to
the project hazel team this week about
are the social aspects because let's to
to get real for a second it it has kind
of sucked for 10 months 10 plus months
we can't see people smile we can't see
their their kind of
the way their excitement in their face
we've only seen half of
everyone's face for the past uh 11
months and it's it has really been
i think it's taken a lot of toll on
people so the social aspects of the mask
are really cool
i've been trying to force myself to be
more of an eyebrow communicator when
we're wearing these
masks and it's just not easy so that was
one of the things i immediately noticed
was just the clear overall plastic
capping here so that
you can actually see what people look
like
under it without sacrificing any of the
safety
and then also thinking about the fact
how many times have you tried to talk to
someone through
a mask you know add a safe distance and
you're trying to push and strain your
voice
over that well you have voice amp
technology from razer in here too so you
can
have comfort knowing that you're
speaking at your normal volume and it's
getting communicated effectively to
whoever you do
i yelling through the masks the whole
show and then
and the whole time and prep for this and
i think that's one thing another cool
thing though is certainly that low light
mode if you think about just being able
to
actually turn on so if you're in a
scenario where it is dark or anything
like that you're actually going to be
able to
see the low light mode kind of lighting
up and being able to give you
that so i think it's pretty fantastic if
you see the lights coming on just a bit
there in the maps probably hard to tell
in this light just because of course we
are daytime here in vegas but
you got actually light kind of that just
illuminates the face just a little bit
which is another great social aspect but
that brings us into
all the sustainable features of the mask
as well yeah i mean i love the low light
right because you don't want it blasting
your face you want it to be
uh nice and lit and when it comes to
that sustainability we're talking about
how
many masks have been donated and things
of the sort but
even how many are used right i think the
latest that we heard from the razer team
was over three million
single-use mass disposed every single
day which first of all
great that everyone is as masking up but
the toll that that's taking
on the environment uh is is pretty
substantial
yeah so you got to think how do you get
around that how do you try and make an
improvement in that aspect in our
footprint that we're making on the earth
and well replaceable
filters having the rechargeable
ventilators these are all aspects that
are going to allow you to be using these
and then the duration itself is actually
applicable
for daily use so it's not like yeah i
went on my dog walk for an hour and then
now i got to go home and charge this
thing up and what am i really going to
do at this point you have that
opportunity
to really enjoy that sustainability a
wireless charging case with a usb
sterilizer by the way
if you didn't know the case is so great
too just the way that that works
right now these prototypes of course
this easy charge cable and you're able
to kind of set everything up so i think
the sustainability of the mask is
incredible but also something that is
super important and
it's hard to say which of these is the
most important but this one's up there
uh just comfort and how this mask sits i
think there's a few things that have to
do with that the first of that's going
to be of course adjustable ear loops
and customizable sizes that they're
thinking about but also not just that
but the
the silicone around the mask i think
that's an important one because
with a lot of these masks you do have
kind of like openings and areas for
droplets to get in and things like that
as we settle into this new normal a mass
that is comfortable
and as safe as it can be is definitely
going to be important yeah and as
somebody i know i'm not alone there's
got to be somebody
watching that also experiences this that
has really sensitive skin
having something completely across the
whole way can be difficult but silicone
on the other hand i mean i haven't had
any issues ever when putting that on my
face so
having something that can still seal
effectively while having that airflow
available so you don't feel suffocated
within it
is really really cool you know what's
also super cool i was going to say
there's one more thing we got to talk
about with this map
very razor-esque i'm going to let you
have the honors gabby all right i
am ready y'all you ready so you know we
showed you low light
we got our actual chroma rgb
on the outside as well so if you do want
to look
extra fancy you definitely can and
that's the greatest thing right i just
want to look cool
i want to look cool while i'm doing the
things uh yeah of course
it would not be a razor concept without
some chroma integration you can see it
right there
um and i think this as you mentioned
gabby not just the way that
of course this being a concept those you
might just be jumping in to check out
this mask reveal
one of the concepts coming out from
razer this year at ces but
uh one of the coolest things about these
two is the way that the case charge and
the ways that
these prototypes charge as well it's
just so easy and i think
uh of all the things that you know we
need from a technological perspective um
this is a pretty exciting one and i'm
you know i got my fingers crossed that
we might see some more from project
hazel in the future
from razer because i'm so excited about
this but we did have a social campaign
you might have seen on twitter
all the razer social channels that kind
of lit up and said we want you to guess
what this year is
this year's ces is about one of the
product unveils and i thought a lot of
people they went to photoshop they
inverted the image they kind of cheated
they saw that it was a mask so many of
you guessed that it was a mask and
that's exactly what project hazel is but
we're going to go ahead and announce
that winner now of that social giveaway
somebody guessed it right somebody is
winning a set of peripherals and that
somebody is stelian langa from romania
congratulations your guessing skills
were on par which means you get rewarded
to boot with those peripherals we're
just giving away so much love today
we really are and i got to say a huge
shout out to the whole razer team and
everyone working on project hazel
because it's so cool to get these
prototypes just got here just before
the show just in time for ces and it's
really exciting to be able to to hear
from them on something that
you know the world really desperately uh
needs innovation in because i think
we're getting tired of the current mass
we're wearing and i think the new normal
has been the new normal for a little bit
too long so i am personally really
excited well that's one of the biggest
things right i think
when wearing the masks people realizing
just how this is the
new normal so if it's something that
you're going to be doing on the daily
you might as well be doing it in the
most
effective and stylish way possible
i love the fact that every time we step
into the store we get to learn about
something new whether it's
project hail hazel with the concept of
the world's smartest mask
or the last time we were here and we got
to learn about the isker because that
was the first official move into the
gaming chair space always bringing
something new to us
absolutely i think it was cool to see
that it was also cool to talk to with
the razer
esker team leads as well talking about
the innovation that they did in terms of
lumbar support that they looked at
competitor gaming chairs what they were
offering what they weren't offering
but the cool news is that here as far as
our second concept announcement we've
got more in store there so let's go
ahead
and check it out